Якщо ми бачимо значне збільшення запитів,
наприклад, про надання притулку з
цих країн, нам потрібен
механізм, щоб на той
момент зупинити лібералізацію візового режиму, головним чином
ці дебати також підживлюються
перспективою угоди між ЄС і Туреччиною, яка  80
мільйонів турків матимуть
можливість у найближчому майбутньому, коли
країна виконає всі критерії, щоб
вільно подорожувати до ЄС – Україні все
ще трохи не вистачає реального
впровадження антикорупційного
законодавства в повсякденну практику
, ще багато чого  корупції на високому рівні,
і в цьому сенсі дуже
добре, що деякі країни-члени втрачають
терпіння, щоб побачити результати, які
ви